>> Tucker: IT'S NOT EXACTLY
THE ROLLING STONES ON TOUR, BUT
HILLARY CLINTON'S ENDLESS
CLINTON WAS RECENTLY IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM WHERE SHE BEGAN
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE AMERICAN
ELECTORAL SYSTEM.
HERE IS A SELECTION.
>> IN THE U.S., IT WAS A PERFECT
STORM.
DEEP CURRENTS OF ANGER AND
RESENTMENT FLOWING THROUGH OUR
WORLD MY EMAILS FOR THE MOST
CAMPAIGN WAGED FROM THE KREMLIN.
>> Tucker: WAGED FROM THE
KREMLIN.
THE DARKEST RESOURCES OF THE
KREMLIN NO DOUBT.
BUT THE 2016 ELECTION IS STILL
ATOP THE CONVERSATION.
THE PRESIDENT BROUGHT IT UP
HIMSELF LAST NIGHT.
>> SHE WRITES A BOOK AND SHE
DOES THE TOUR.
HOW MANY REASONS THAT SHE GIVE
FOR USING       LOSING THE ELECT
FOR USING       LOSING THE ELECO
REASON.
OBVIOUSLY A FREQUENT AND
TREASURED GUEST ON THIS SHOW.
I DON'T WANT TO CARRY WATER FOR
THE KREMLIN, BUT I CAN'T RESIST
ASKING.
I'M STILL BAFFLED.
>> IT MATCHES WHAT WE WERE
DISCUSSING EARLIER IN THE SHOW
BASED IN EMOTION, NO FACTS, IT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH POLICY
AND EVERYTHING TO DO WITH SOME
UP SESSION IF YOU WILL, AND
RAGE.
SHE IS ON FOREIGN SOIL, IN
ADDITION, AND YET NOW, SHE'S NOT
ONLY CONFRONTING TRUMP ABOUT
POLICY, OR ABOUT HAVING BETTER
TURKEY'S TYRANNICAL LEADER WHO
JUST GOT REELECTED.
BUT SHE STILL, PERSONALLY FOR
SOME REASON, CAN'T RESOLVE THE
FACT THAT SHE FAILED.
THAT THIS WAS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND WHEN SHE TALKS ABOUT A
RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY, IT REALLY
WAS ABOUT THE SIMPLE BASIC
DECISIONS IN THE CAMPAIGN LIKE
NOT GOING TO WISCONSIN.
TO THAT FAILURE.
>> Tammy: YES.
AS A WOMAN, AND I WANT WOMEN IN
POWER, WE ARE TERRIFIC LEADERS.
THE FACT THAT THIS HAS BECOME AN
ALMOST STEREOTYPICAL CARTOON OF
WHAT HAPPENS WITH A WOMAN,
WE DON'T LOOK AND DEAL WITH THE
THIS IS NOT HELPFUL.
IT IS A SHAME AND, AT THE SAME
TIME, YOU ARE ARGUING -- AND
WHEN SHE ARGUES AGAINST THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AS AN EXAMPLE,
SHE IS ARGUING THAT THE ENTIRE
REPUBLICAN STRUCTURE OF THE
UNITED STATES IS AT FAULT AS
WELL.
IT'S A FOUNDERS NOW WHO ARE THE
REPRESENTATION ALSO OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE AT HOME WITH THE
LEFT AND WHAT'S GOING ON NOW
WITH ALL OF THE HARASSMENT AND
VIOLENCE.
>> NOT HELPFUL.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.